one quick Google search would have you
believe that we're in the worst
recession since 2008 hundreds of
thousands of people have been laid off
companies have shedded trillions of
dollars worth of market cap and
inflation has been off the charts but at
this same time several other metrics
would suggest that things are going just
fine I mean just take a look at the
billionaires list the vast majority of
billionaires are up substantially this
year and the most notable ones are of
the most Elon Musk up 110 billion Jeff
Bezos up 47 billion and the Mark
Zuckerberg of 58 billion the same thing
can be said about most notable stocks as
well Netflix has recovered 175 percent
meta has recovered over 200 percent and
as for apple and Nvidia well these guys
are straight up setting all-time highs
Apple has surpassed a three trillion
dollar market cap and Nvidia has joined
the trillion dollar Club also it's not
just these big tech companies that are
doing well either McDonald's
all-time high and even Bitcoin one of
the riskiest assets on the planet has
bounced back a hundred percent as such I
don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that the S P 500 is also doing pretty
well the index has recovered 27 and it's
only seven and a half percent away from
all-time highs inflation has also cooled
down substantially to just four percent
by the time you're watching this
inflation may even be indeed three
percent range margin levels have also
dropped significantly from nearly 8
trillion dollars down the pre-pandemic
levels of 644 billion so where exactly
is all this fear coming from why are
companies seemingly bracing for some
sort of a Great Depression type event
and why are Finance YouTubers constantly
saying that the collapse is just around
the corner oh wait that's just for the
views but what about the first point
what do companies know that we don't are
all these stock rallies just fake out
before we plunge far deeper into a big
bad recession or has this Market
correction simply been vastly overhyped
since the very beginning join me as we
uncover the truth behind the 2023
recession AKA The Great reset
foreign
first of all we are not in a recession
economically speaking a recession is
defined as two quarters of GDP decline
this is the graph of America's GDP over
the past five years clearly there has
been no such decline since the beginning
of the pandemic but but wait a minute
weren't we in a mild recession in 2022 I
swear there were articles claiming that
we were officially in a recession well
there actually wasn't any articles that
were claiming that if we set our search
time frame to the second half of last
year and look up U.S enters a recession
we'll see that every single reputable
news Outlet frame the topic as a
question as opposed to a statement of
fact the ones that were claiming it as
fact were actually just YouTubers and I
may have been guilty of this as well now
there is some truth to what they were
saying what these guys were looking at
was real GDP or inflation-adjusted GDP
here there was indeed a substantial
decline from 20 trillion to 19.9
trillion or a whopping 0.5 percent and
as you can see the decline was virtually
nothing for perspective the coveted
recession was nearly 10 but that's just
the most blatant issue with calling this
a recession for starters even by the
traditional definition a recession
refers to nominal GDP decline not
inflation-adjusted GDP decline this is
why the 2020 recession is highlighted
with a gray bar while the supposed 2022
recession is not but more importantly
this rule is just a general idea if
there's two consecutive quarters of a
GDP decline then hey maybe the economy
is not doing so great but the reality is
that there's so many more factors that
are needed to gauge real economic health
than just the GDP for example you may
also want to consider the unemployment
rate non-farm payroll industrial
production and retail sales just to name
a few here's a graph of unemployment for
example literally at all time lows So
objectively speaking we were never in a
recession in 20 22 but what about
looking forward what about the 2023 and
2024 recession and the great reset well
every day that's looking less and less
likely as well for a recession to happen
we would first need to build up some
negative momentum you know things like
increasing unemployment the more layoffs
lower salaries and so on but not only is
this not happening but the exact
opposite is happening we're gaining
positive momentum layoffs have
substantially slowed down with the peak
being back in January in fact the
layoffs this June were actually lower
than layoffs last June payroll growth
has also gained some positive momentum
with April and May being positive months
also as we touched on at the beginning
inflation has cooled off quite well and
that blue chip stocks are doing better
than anyone expected with that being
said the general fear was simply a case
of the general public eating up media
and YouTube fear mongering but what
about big tech stocks initially these
guys got destroyed due to big money
selling off big money clearly has more
insight than the general public right
why were they so scared of a potential
recession and especially interest rates
foreign
by far the number one thing that was
referenced as the big tech company
killer was Rising interest rates
basically the entirety of big Tech
happened within the past 15 years during
which interest rates were literally zero
so there was a lot of anxiety regarding
how high interest rates would affect
these massive growth companies but
there's just one fatal flaw with this
concern most of the biggest tech
companies in the world are no longer
growth companies to begin with yes they
still put up insane growth numbers year
after year but that's not at the cost of
profit traditional growth companies
sacrifice profitability to achieve
growth likely the best examples are Uber
and all of the food delivery apps but
this is not the case with Google or
Apple or Facebook or Microsoft I'm sure
you already know how profitable these
companies are but let's go through their
annual net profit for fun Apple 112
billion dollars Microsoft 85 billion
dollars and the Google 71 billion
dollars
do you really think that these companies
were Suddenly at risk due to interest
rates rising from two percent to five
percent of course not and this has
become abundantly clear within the past
12 months take Apple for example they
have a total of 100 billion dollars in
debt for one most of this debt was
locked 10 years ago so it's not like
apple is having to pay a whole lot more
all of a sudden but even if we assume
that all of Apple's debt was affected by
the interest rate hikes it's not that
big of a deal even if Apple's rates got
hiked from two percent up to seven
percent we're only talking about an
extra five billion dollars it's crazy to
refer to that as only but at Apple scale
it truly is just only with 112 billion
dollars worth of annual profit an extra
5 billion dollars would only reduce
their profitability by four and a half
percent and that's if the interest hit
their bottom line directly you can bet
that they're gonna write the interest
off on taxes so the real cost of
profitability would be like three
percent in other words most of the big
tech companies are completely unaffected
by the rate hikes now if we're talking
about specs and hype plays that's a
whole other story but to be honest those
deserve to get wrecked anyway
companies with the strong fundamentals
really had no issues but that's only
half the puzzle the other argument was
that investors would no longer be
interested in these companies when you
can make a five percent guaranteed by
lending to the government or seven
percent by lending to Big corporations
with bonds why in the world would you
invest in stocks well this does have
some truth to it if you're a
conservative investor the answer is no
reason at all statistically speaking the
average investor has no chance of
beating average market returns of seven
to eight percent so if you can get
nearly the same thing with the bonds why
invest in something that's far riskier
well the answer is that that's literally
the job of most of big money while they
too suck at beating the market their job
is indeed to try to beat the market the
best way to do that over the past 10
years was to invest in big Tech will
this work again well no one knows
especially with AI making big leaps but
one thing is for sure a lot of big money
is rotating back into Tech despite all
the fear but if there's no recession and
the big tech companies are doing just
fine why in the world did we see so many
layoffs
naturally everyone Associates layoffs
with recessions so when even the biggest
name started laying off everyone assumed
that we were surely in a recession or
that we were heading into one shortly
but that's not actually the case you see
much of the layoffs weren't caused by
some sort of macroeconomic trend but
rather microeconomic Trends within Tech
by far the biggest factor of throwing
things off balance over the past few
years was coveted when kovid showed up
and everyone hunkered down people
naturally flocked to things that they
could do at home this meant more time
spent on Netflix social media
smartphones computers and the internet
as such the demand for these products
skyrocketed in fact many tech companies
had to scale their operations
specifically to keep up with this demand
the problem was that many of these
companies assumed that this was the new
normal and that demand would continue
growing at this rate as such they hired
a crap ton of employees Google's
employee counter exploded from 118 000
to hundred and ninety thousand
Facebook's employee count exploited from
forty five thousand to eighty six
thousand and Amazon's employee account
exploded from 800 000 to 1.6 million as
you might guess these guys were in for
quite a rude awakening when people
started spending money elsewhere on
eating out vacations music festivals
physical stores transportation and so on
people never stopped spending money
that's why our GDP has continued to grow
but people did pull back on their Tekken
take whether that be in terms of time or
money this was especially true for
pandemic specific tech companies like
Zoom who have simply gotten obliterated
at the same time that growth numbers
were slowing down productivity numbers
were also slowing down you see all of
this crazy hiring naturally brought in a
lot of subpar people into these
companies existing employees also became
a lot less productive because well they
added 10 job offers waiting outside so
they were by no means scared of getting
fired you also had all these trendy
movements like quiet quitting basically
all of this simply meant that these
companies were dealing with more rest
investors than ever for obvious reasons
this put companies at quite a big hiring
disadvantage not only were they
constantly having to offer larger and
larger compensation packages but the
employees that they were hiring were
less and less effective it was a
lose-lose scenario for these companies
fortunately for them layoffs gave them
the perfect way to work their way out of
this vicious cycle so all of these
layoffs that we read about on the news
aren't pretty indicative of the
macroeconomic climate it's really just
indicative of the tech World which did
indeed have a correction coming off the
pandemic High zooming out though we're
not in a recession but a recession is
inevitable with that being said though
no one knows when that's gonna be when
everyone thinks that it's gonna be in 6
or 12 months that's how you know that
it's definitely not going to be in 6 or
12 months you can't expect a recession
if everyone expects a recession they'll
do things to prepare for the downturn
which in turn will prevent the recession
from even happening recessions happen
when the general public is overconfident
in the market which is definitely not
the case right now so the best option is
to just forget trying to predict the
next recession and stick to a strong
investment plan that works out over the
long term whether that be buying the S P
500 or investing in bonds but that's
just what I think someone that's
actually facing a recession is
tick-tockers check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]